and so you'll see he said why is he
getting arrested and the officer said
he's stronger now the reason that the
officer said that is because under the
duth model it's typically um and I can't
remember the actual wording but the duth
model switched the way that police do
policing in around the 80s and what this
did um was basically assuming women the
stronger person has power and is trying
to use that against the weaker person um
the person that is stronger which is
typically men is the person that is seen
to be the abuser that's why you see
these men that call the police and then
the women um end up the men will call
the police on the women and then the men
get arrested like we we've seen case
after case after case of this um